la bonne vieille saucisses à des jeunes
est un produit qui viennent agrémenter
nos repas familiaux du matin depuis des
générations dans mon enfance on allait à
la ferme
et puis à ce moment-là il tuait le
cochon puis pas longtemps après on
pouvait avoir des saucisses pire faisait
des soucis sur des années ce qui
distingue ou définit davantage associés
à des jeunes et c'est pas parce que
l'industrie a défini en fait est un des
précurseurs de ça et là mark lafleur qui
a lancé y'en centaines d'années
maintenant
la première société à déjeuner qui est
encore aujourd'hui la marque numéro un
ça c'est vraiment le déjeuner
traditionnel qui attend vos restaurants
pour but la sauce us évidemment la
société dans tous les bons des jeunes et
ça fait vraiment déjeuner traditionnel
on les connaît elles sont minces grâce
et salue et je pense que c'est ce que
les gens recherchent un peu aussi dans
cette suite de produits le goût de
viande salée ou tout simplement pour moi
ça reste un aliment plaisir ou même site
quelle bécane le marché de la saucisse à
déjeuner a beau être traditionnel on
voit poindre de nouveaux joueurs
certains biologique d'autres proposent
d'intégrer des protéines végétales comme
le soya c'est le cas des produits quévy
vendu congelé et qui sont confectionnés
sans boyau ce qui leur donne une
apparence unique
somain sauvier de demain de ma mère a
fabriqué sa date en direct puis appuyez
sur a séduit main puis mettez au
congélateur puis moi mais de sang a
notamment atteint le point le matin de
bonne heure pour à croquer le fait de
vendre le produit congelé permet aussi
de ne pas utiliser d'agents de
conservation
en plus des saucisses en boyau nous
avons choisi aux fins de notre test du
goût amicale des saucisses avec boyau
végétal fabriqués à partir de l'extrait
d'agde liquide l'alginate de calcium ou
de sodium qui durcit sur la chair à
saucisse c'est ce qui donne et saucisses
plus tendre comparativement à
l'utilisation d'un boyau naturel le
boyau naturel c'est en fait une fine
couche de la paroi de l'intestin dans
l'animal habituellement de porc ou
d'agneau ce qui est utilisé en
charcuterie artisanale depuis défié
parmi les 28 produits de notre
échantillonnage nous avons choisi cinq
saucisses qui seront dégustés par
estelle jacques et colette de vétérans
mangeurs de saucisses à déjeuner pour
leurs qualités nutritionnelles nous
avons mais boris naturel qu'est vivo et
tofu et rennes talent bio une
incontournable
lafleur porc et boeuf léger et il arrive
belgique within sans protéines animales
mais avec une très longue liste
d'ingrédients ils ont choisi de la
goûter en premier
saleh unanime aux fables ils n'ont pas
non plus aimé la met police bri hqe au
final je pense et je parle pour les
sociétés déjà les lélés sont
relativement courtes 5 2 agents de
remplissage et autres additifs pour
ajuster la texture la saveur et la
conservation du produit bien sûr la
viande de porc qu'on retrouve le plus
mais aussi le mélange paris boeuf qui
serait le meilleur vendeur dans la sauce
essais des jeunes et ça semble être la
plus populaire chez qui vit on innove en
intégrant une protéine végétale pour
entre autres diminuer les gras saturés
la plupart des sources et sur nos jeunes
jouent de flux moi j'ai commencé ça
parce que je voulais y aller un petit
peu plus dans le végétal
mais c'est pas une affaire ben facile
puis on veut encore l'améliorer dans le
futur la façon de deux places et moins
de viande
moi je me moquais en ce qui a trait au
sodium
rappelons nous qu'en 2016 santé canada
avait fixé des objectifs pour encourager
l'industrie a diminué son utilisation
dans le cas des sociétés à déjeuner on
rate la cible
et de loin sur les échantillons qu'on a
regardé une plus de la moitié
contiennent entre 25 et 30 4% mais ce
qu'on appelle l'apport maximal tolérable
en sodium pour deux joueuses pour deux
saucisses c'est le tiers de la quantité
maximum que vous pouvez consommer avant
d'avoir des effets négatifs sur la santé
petit charcutier n'a de petits que le
nom avec près de 700 mg de sodium pour
deux saucisses on est généreux aussi
chez yves lafleur agréé et
fernand dire on a trois marques dans le
fauteuil sortent du lot positivement je
veux dire en matière de sodium la gamme
kelly et en particulier leurs saucisses
de veau les saucisses biologique brenton
et la gamme demi police
revenons aux tests de goût la saucisse
lafleur qui figurent parmi les plus
vendus à réveiller leurs papilles et
josiane la dernière saucisses qu'ils ont
goûté la reine talent biologique sans
gluten elle les pc boyer type si l'eau
n'est déjà plus de la moitié des
produits étudiés contiennent au moins
seize grammes de gras surtout saturé
c'est entre 25 et 45 % de nos besoins
quotidiens en lipides ma nutrition au
final ils ont préféré la saucisse qui
vit vaud est au fût ainsi que la
saucisse biologique
wrenshall ces deux choix font aussi
partie des recommandations d'isabelle
marquis dans l'ensemble de ce qu'on a
évalué quand même quelques produits qui
sortent du lot et se démarque
positivement à savoir notamment la gamme
de m'épauler autant leurs produits frais
que leurs produits surgelés
on a aussi toute la gamme de quévy qui
se sortait très très bien à tous les
niveaux on à la fleur avec leurs
produits par les boeufs qui désigne les
nôtres seuls produits biologiques rento
qui est évidemment plus cher que les
autres de par sa certification notamment
mais qui globalement nous offrez la plus
belle les ingrédients
tallaght stadium tout à fait raisonnable
la plus haute est à l'art en protéines
récit
[Musique]